okay today I'm going to talk to you
about renewable energy sources we're
going to look at what is meant by
renewable energy we're going to look at
five different types of renewable energy
and for each one we're gonna have a look
at their advantages and the
disadvantages so first of all renewable
energy source is an energy source that
won't run out so it's a way of
generating electricity that we could use
again and again and again they are much
better for the environment than using
non-renewable energy I've done a
different video about non renewable
energy when you can learn about non
renewable energy
now also compared to the downside of
them it's the fact that they don't
currently with current technology
produce as much energy as non renewable
energy sources so that is one of the
negatives so the first one we're going
to learn about is a type of renewable
energy source called biofuels now
whenever you see the prefix bio it means
living things
so what biofuels are means generating
electricity from plants and also from
animal dung now to get the energy from
them this for example with the plants
they're grown harvested and then they
are burnt to release energy and so is
the dung to find out exactly how
electricity is generated from burning
them please watch another video about
non renewable energy because it's
similar to how you get electricity from
burning coal so an advantage of this is
of burning plants and biofuels is its
carbon neutral now this might sound
weird because when you burn it it does
release carbon dioxide the reason why
this doesn't cause an overall net
increase in carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere is during the plant's
lifetime they take in carbon dioxide
through the process of photosynthesis
so when you burn the plants it just
returns the co2 to the atmosphere also
the plants could be grown at certain
times during the year and then stored
for later the negative size about
biofuels is it's a very expensive way to
generate all of your electricity also a
big problem is by growing all of these
crops in fields it takes up valuable
space which could be used to grow food
so those are the issues with biofuels
the next type of renewable energy source
we're looking at is wind power now you
probably have seen wind turbines in
fields before that look a little bit
like my drawing here so basically the
way that it operates is you have a
turbine which turns when the wind hits
the turbine it is then connected to this
part here which is a corded generator
which generates electricity now the
positive things about wind power just
like many of these types of renewable
energy is they release they don't
release any carbon dioxide so they don't
release any pollutants into the air also
once it's built it actually has cheap
running costs so it's not expensive once
the actual turbines are built in the
first place
now a few people complain that they
think they're ugly and noisy they can
also be quite expensive to build in the
first place now the big negative when it
comes to wind power is it must be windy
in order for them to work so on a really
non windy day they're not going to be
generating much energy if any energy at
all the third one we're going to learn
about are called solar cells so solar
cells you've probably seen these on the
roofs of certain houses but essentially
the way that it works is you have light
so usually sunlight that hits these
solar cells and it converts that energy
directly to electricity
now the advantages of this is you can
have these solar cells in really remote
places where other types of electricity
generation would not be suitable they're
also once they're built they they are
extremely cheap to run so once they're
built it's essentially not having to
spend much money on the upkeep of them
at all now the massive negative about
solar cells is they do not work at night
time when there is no sunlight to hit
the cells obviously there'll be no
electricity being generated the other
big problem with them is they're really
expensive to make in the first place so
once they're built they're really cheap
to run but it's expensive to make them
initially the next type of renewable
energy is hydroelectric power
hydroelectric or hydroelectricity so the
way that hydroelectric power works is
this there's a what happens is there's a
river what people do is they build a dam
across the river and this dam causes
flooding of the area behind what then
happens is at a slightly different level
so like at a lower level the river
continues underneath so what happens for
hydroelectricity is water is let through
the dam and within the dam there were
lots of turbines a little bit like in
wind power but there are turbines in the
dam that turn when the water drops
through so essentially that's how
hydroelectric power works now the
positive side the positive side of it is
hydroelectric power is really good for
meeting energy or energy demand so for
example if a city suddenly needed lots
and lots more electricity they just let
more water pass through the dam turning
the turbines at a faster rate or a
greater rate producing more electricity
they're also extremely reliable
now the downside of them is first of all
it causes the destruction of habitats
that's where animals live so when we
initially build the dam and flood the
surroundings it kill it basically
destroys lots of animals habitats it's
also extremely expensive to build one of
these dams in the first place now the
final type of renewable energy we're
going to look at are tidal barrages now
a tidal barrage works like this here I
have a river meeting the sea so this bit
here when I'm shading in green this is
the land and this bit here is the sea so
where you have the river meeting the the
sea you have an estuary which is just
the name of the bit where the river
meets the sea and the tidal barrages
built over the estuary now the way that
it works is again we have turbines
within the dam that turn when the tide
comes in and when the tide goes out now
the positive side of it again is they're
very reliable because the tides are very
reliable we can rely upon the tides
unlike for example the wind like many of
these different types of energy they
release no co2 once they're built now
for negative points about tidal barrages
similar to hydroelectric is it can often
damage animals habitats destroy their
habitats that's where they live when
it's built in the first place the other
negative point about tidal barrages is
it really affect boat access up and down
the estuary so guys that is basically a
summary summary of five different types
of renewable energy their advantages and
the disadvantages thank you